Let us now revisit the variance
and see what happens
in the case of independence.
Variances have some general
properties that we have
already seen.
However, since we often add
random variables, we would
like to be able to say something
about the variance
of the sum of two random
variables.
Unfortunately, the situation
is not so simple, and in
general, the variance of the sum
is not the same as the sum
of the variances.
We will see an example
shortly.
On the other hand, when X and
Y are independent, the
variance of the sum is equal to
the sum of the variances,
and this is a very
useful fact.
Let us go through the derivation
of this property.
But to keep things simple, let
us assume just for the sake of
the derivation, that the two
random variables have 0 mean.
So in that case, the variance
over the sum is just the
expected value of the
square of the sum.
And we can expand the quadratic
and write this as
the expectation of X squared
plus 2 X Y plus Y squared.
Then we use linearity of
expectations to write this as
the expected value of X
squared plus twice the
expected value of X times Y
and then plus the expected
value of Y squared.
Now, the first term is just the
variance of X because we
have assumed that
we have 0 mean.
The last term is similarly the
variance of Y. How about the
middle term?
Because of independence, the
expected value of the product
is the same as the product of
the expected values, and the
expected values are
0 in our case.
So this term, because of
independence, is going to be
equal to 0.
In particular, what we have is
that the expected value of XY
equals the expected value of X
times the expected value of Y,
equal to 0.
And so we have verified that
indeed the variance of the sum
is equal to the sum
of the variances.
Let us now look at
some examples.
Suppose that X is the same
random variable as Y. Clearly,
this is a case where
independence fails to hold.
If I tell you the value of X,
then you know the value of Y.
So in this case, the variance of
the sum is the same as the
variance of twice X. Since X is
the same as Y, X plus Y is
2 times X. And then using this
property for the variance,
what happens when we multiply
by a constant?
This is going to be 4 times
the variance of X.
In another example, suppose that
X is the negative of Y.
In that case, X plus Y is
identically equal to 0.
So we're dealing with a
random variable that
takes a constant value.
In particular, it is always
equal to its mean, and so the
difference from the mean is
always equal to 0, and so the
variance will also
evaluate to 0.
So we see that the variance
of the sum can take quite
different values depending on
the sort of interrelation that
we have between the two
random variables.
So these two examples indicate
that knowing the variance of
each one of the random variables
is not enough to say
much about the variance
of the sum.
The answer will generally depend
on how the two random
variables are related to each
other and what kind of
dependencies they have.
As a last example, suppose now
that X and Y are independent.
X is independent from Y,
and therefore X is also
independent from minus 3Y.
Therefore, this variance is
equal to the sum of the
variances of X and
of minus 3Y.
And using the facts that we
already know, this is going to
be equal to the variance of X
plus 9 times the variance of
Y.
As an illustration of the
usefulness of the property of
the variance that we have just
established, we will now use
it to calculate the variance of
a binomial random variable.
Remember that a binomial with
parameters n and p corresponds
to the number of successes
in n independent trials.
We use indicator variables.
This is the same trick that we
used to calculate the expected
value of the binomial.
So the random variable X sub
i is equal to 1 if the i-th
trial is a success and
is a 0 otherwise.
And as we did before, we note
that X, the total number of
successes, is the sum of those
indicator variables.
Each success makes one of those
variables equal to 1, so
by adding those indicator
variables, we're just counting
the number of successes.
The key point to note is that
the assumption of independence
that we're making is essentially
the assumption
that these random variables Xi
are independent of each other.
So we're dealing with a
situation where we have a sum
of independent random variables,
and according to
what we have shown, the variance
of X is going to be
the sum of the variances
of the Xi's.
Now, the Xi's all have the same
distribution so all these
variances will be the same.
It suffices to consider
one of them.
Now, X1 is a Bernoulli random
variable with parameter p.
We know what its variance is--
it is p times 1 minus p.
And therefore, this is the
formula for the variance of a
binomial random variable.